Salut, aujourd'hui on est mercredi.
c'est donc le jour de l'astuce du mercredi.
Je sais que vous regardez le tee-shirt. J'ai eu pleins de messages dans les commentaires depuis 3 semaines
On me demande "Qu'est ce que c'est que ce tee-shirt?"
Alors je vais vous le faire voir: Là c'est le fantôme qui est en train d'essayer de ne pas se faire manger par Pacman
Vous m'avez aussi demandé: "Où est qu'on pouvait l'acheter?"
Je ne peux pas vraiment vous répondre,
en fait je l'ai acheté à Camden Town.
C'est au Nord de Londres avec pleins pleins de boutiques partout
c'est vraiment rigolo d'ailleurs, tu peux passer une journée, une semaine même juste là-bas.
à te perdre  dans les boutiques et à dépenser tout ton argent en même temps
vous pouvez prendre quelques minutes pour regarder la vidéo de Londres
Je vous avais aussi posé une question pour savoir si vous vouliez plus d'astuces, plus d'explications de mentalismes
je vous ai posé la question dimanche, on est aujourd'hui mercredi
Et voici ce que j'en ai retiré
Vous en voudriez un petit peu plus mais pas trop non plus
alors comme quoi j'ai bien fait de vous posez la question
parce que j'avais l'impression que vous en vouliez beaucoup plus d'explication
donc je vais trouver un juste milieu
à partir de samedi je vais lancer encore un autre rendez-vous sur YouTube *rires*
Je passe ma vie à créer des rendez-vous avec vous
le samedi ça ne sera pas un MentalVlog comme les autres, ça sera de l'astuce en plus pousser
ça sera pas un cour, c'est pas une formation parce que j'ai pas du tout la prétention de vous formez à quoi que ce soit
Disons que la semaine j'essaie quand même de faire des choses un peu plus rapide.
un peu plus dynamique
qu'on assimile facilement
Je pense que le samedi, je vais pousser ça un petit peu plus loin
Donc je filmerai le 1er depuis Aix en Provence puisque je suis de mercredi jusqu'à dimanche à Aix en Provence
au café théâtre La Fontaine d'Argent d'ailleurs si tu veux venir me voir
Et je vais appeler ça le Master Class du samedi, c'est un niveau au dessus de l'astuce
ça sera des vidéos un petit plus technique, un peu plus longue
applicable par tout le monde mais forcément pour les appliquer il faudra passer un petit moment à les écouter
et voir même à s'entraîner
Voilà j'ai fait mes petites annonces
Vraiment je suis étonné de cette réponse. J'avais même l'impression que vous vouliez beaucoup plus d'explications et tout
Comme quoi ça vaut le coup que nous communiquions ensemble.
Continuez à mettre des commentaires, même simplement des pouces en l'air sous la vidéo ça permet aussi de savoir que
celle ci vous plait particulièrement, que le sujet vous plaît, que le format vous plait. Je vous observe par la webcam
à travers le logiciel espion que j'ai installé la dernière fois que tu as liké
Ne t'inquiète pas il y a rien d'installer tout vas bien
inutile de te mettre du papier d'aluminium autour de la tête
Astuce du mercredi donc c'est en rapport avec la mémoire
ça je l'avais annoncé. Du coup, je ne vais pas parler durant des heures, vous expliquez le fonctionnement de la mémoire etc...
Ça sera plus pour le samedi
pour l'astuce je vais juste vous apprendre à retenir un numéro de téléphone facilement à la volée
quand on vous donne un numéro de téléphone pour le retenir, vous le mettez dans votre mémoire à court terme, ou voir même à très courte terme
Tu l'as connais cette mémoire à très courte terme, c'est celle où tu mets l'heure quand tu regardes ton téléphone
tu regardes l'heure tu le repose à peine une seconde après, si on te demande l'heure tu fais : "Euh je sais plus"
il faut que tu regardes à nouveau
C'est normal tu l'as mis dans ta mémoire à très court terme
et bien tu fais pareil pour les numéros de téléphone
On peut quand même le retenir dans la mémoire à moyen terme facilement
en utilisant des moyens de mnémotechnique très simple
Je sais que tu ne m'as pas attendu pour appliquer des moyens de mnémotechnie pour retenir quelques choses
c'est sûr et certains
Mais je vais rendre ça peut être un peu plus efficace
Si je te donne un numéro de téléphone au hasard
06.22.03.53.17
admettons
N'appelle pas c'est pas quelqu'un que je connais. Je viens vraiment de dire ça au pif
Pour le retenir comment tu ferais
Soit tu le répéterais en boucle
donc là on est toujours dans la mémoire à court terme
Soit tu vas trouver des petites astuces pour le mémoriser
par exemple si tu es né le 22, ce qui est le cas pour moi, je suis né un 22 ça va me marquer
je vais trouver ça significatif et je vais plus facilement m'en rappeler
mais tu peux prendre le temps de le faire, voir même t'imaginer une histoire avec
Pour imaginer une histoire, quand on a pas l'habitude
de faire travailler son imaginaire
je recommande de fermer les yeux
donc tu peux fermer les yeux pour le faire
sinon tu peux regarder la vidéo en même temps, il y a pas de soucis
mais il faut développer ton imaginaire pour bien fixer cette mnémotechnie
On a dit quoi 06.22.03.53.17 je crois que c'est ça que je vous ai dit à l'instant
Vidéo sur la mémoire déjà je me rappelle plus ce que je vous ai dit
Champion du monde
Alors voici l'histoire que je propose pour fixer ce numéro de téléphone
06 on l'oublie tout les numéros de téléphone comme par 06 en général
22 c'est la police. 22 V'là les flics
ok donc imagine que tu as un policier
et il tombe sur qui? il tombe sur les 3 petits cochons
ok sur les 3 petits cochons.
Donc on imagine le policier qui marche et qui arrête les 3 petits cochons
les 3 petits cochons ils ont quoi dans les mains. Ils ont 3 bouteilles de Pastis chacun
ils ont chacun 3 bouteilles de pastis
chacun a ces 3 bouteilles de pastis
ils viennent de les voler d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'il les arrête
donc on imagine le policier en train d'arrêter les 3 petits cochons
parce qu'ils étaient en train de cambrioler 3 bouteilles de pastis chacun
Ça va jusque là je ne t'ai pas encore perdu?!
On va imaginer que les 3 petits cochons s'enfuient avec les bouteilles, qu'ils arrivent à courir.
et ils se cachent où? ils se cachent dans les 2 grandes tours. Les 2 grandes tours qu'il y a dans le port de la Rochelle
La tour de la Chaîne et la tour de la Lanterne
pourquoi ils se cachent dans les tours parce que la Rochelle c'est la Charente-Maritime. Et la Charente-Maritime c'est le 17
on aurait pu aussi pu qu'en fait ils s'aperçoivent que c'est un faux policier et que du coup ils décident eux même d'appeler la police
et ils composent le 17
ce qui nous donnerais une scénette cohérente puisqu'on aurait
Le policier qui marche. Il tombe sur les 3 petits cochons qui sont en train de voler 3 bouteilles de pastis 51 chacun.
3 chacun
Il leur court après pour les arrêter. Les 3 petits cochons se rendent compte que c'est un faux policier. Ils appellent eux-même la police
pour vérifier en prenant leur téléphone, c'est Naf naf en même temps et il compose le 17
Bienvenue dans mon monde
Pourquoi cette scène là? Je vous l'ai dis parce que au départ 22 pour la police
tu vois le policier fait penser à 22 aux flics
Les 3 petits cochons parce que 3 donc 22.03
Pourquoi 3 bouteilles de Pastis alors ça c'est mon délire à moi. C'est à dire
de 51 à 55 je pense toujours à une bouteille de Pastis
si, il y a 2 bouteilles je pense à 52,
Si y as 3 bouteilles c'est 53
Si y'a 4 bouteilles 54 si y'en 5: 55
et à la fin ils ont appelé la police donc 17 pour le coup de fil à la police ou ils se sont cachés dans les tours de la Rochelle
ce qui me fait penser au 17 pour la Charente-maritime
Est ce que tu es en train de comprendre comment on fait?
Et oui c'est assez simple à faire en fait
et j'aurai pu même associer la personne à qui appartient le numéro de téléphone
en imaginant cette personne là en policier
Je te fais un récapitulatif
pour retenir ce numéro de téléphone spécifiquement
j'aurai imaginer la personne à qui appartient le numéro en policier dans ma tête
je l'aurai imaginé en train de jouer aux dés
ensuite de se lever de la table où elle jouait aux dés
et de tomber sur les 3 petits cochons en train de chourer chacun 3 bouteilles de Pastis 51
et ensuite j'aurai vu, dans ma tête toujours, les 3 petits cochons s'enfuirent en courant pour se cacher dans les tours de la Rochelle
Et pour me souvenir du numéro, une heure après ou le soir même pour le noter
voir même le lendemain parce que ça tient quelques jours. C'est du moyen terme
J'aurai juste à imaginer la personne
et à partir de là toute l'action qui en découle
elle me serait revenu parce qu'il y a une logique en fait
notre cerveau aime ça. Et notre mémoire aime se nourrir d'imaginaire
de choses logiques, de choses cohérentes. Elle aime pas trop l'abstrait
Elle aime pas trop ce qui correspond à rien
Elle aime bien les vraies images
Et tout ce qui est incongrue
donc si vous vous amusez à utiliser de la mnémotechnie
avec un vrai temps de mémorisation et d'imagination
vous allez retenir les numéros de téléphone à la volée
Ce que je vous recommande c'est sur un temps mort, par exemple,
en voiture, ou dans un train ou dans les transports en communs peu importe
d'imaginer des images mentales, des accroches que vous pourriez avoir en fait
qu'est ce que vous imagineriez pour 1
pour 2, pour 3, pour 4, etc... jusqu'à 99
Ça prend pas énormément de temps
c'est juste pour avoir fait au moins une fois le travail
d'imagination préalable que vous ne soyez pas bloquer à cause d'un chiffre en particulier
Donc voici l'astuce du mercredi
pour retenir un numéro de téléphone à moyen terme
vous essayez de trouver une mnémotechnie à chaque numéro. Une rapide, une qui vous parait cohérente
qui vous correspond à vous
Ensuite vous construisez une action, une petite scénette
avec toutes ces images qui passent une par une avec un action logique
ou illogique mais il faut qu'il y ai un lien entre chaques images
vous associez si possible le visage de la personne dont vous voulez retenir le numéro
et jusqu'au soir, jusqu'au lendemain voir au surlendemain
voir une semaine après pour les plus entraînés
vous vous souviendrez de ce numéro de téléphone
Le but c'est pas de le retenir pour toute la vie. Le but c'est de le retenir assez longtemps pour pouvoir le re-noter ailleurs
pour pouvoir le stocker sur un laps de temps raisonnable avant de pouvoir se décharger dans un calepin par exemple
Voilà c'était l'astuce du mercredi, qui était, un petit peu, basé sur la mémoire
J'espère que ça vous a plu
Samedi il y aura donc le 1er MasterClass
en fait, ça fait hyper prétentieux
mais c'est trop tard je l'ai appelé comme ça maintenant
dimanche pour l'explication
et d'ici là les MentalVlog comme tous les jours
Ça va faire un rapport de 4 sur 3 entre le fait que vous êtes en train de devenir des petits mentalisateurs
et le fait de vous faire voir mon quotidien en mentalisant les gens que je rencontre
Si cette nouvelle astuce vous a plu, mettez un pouce en l'air comme ça, ça me motive à en faire c'est très important
Et abonnez vous à la chaîne YouTube. Abonnez vous. Abonnez vous
Abonnez vous, c'est moins compliqué que de retenir un numéro de téléphone de s'abonner
Tu cliques et hop tu t'abonnes
Et je vous dis à demain 17h pour le nouveau MentalVlog. Ciao!